-Welcome back.
We are hanging out with Halsey,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Halsey, I like to think that --
I like to think
that we are friends.
But I was wondering,
are we best friends?
-Yes.
-And I have a game
where we can play to prove it.
It is time for
the "Best Friends Challenge."
Here we go.
♪ Best Friends Challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Oh, my God.
It's happening right now.
-The game works like
"The Newlywed Game"
but for friends.
We're gonna take turns
reading questions about each
other from the Best Friends Box.
Okay?
This right here.
We're gonna try to write down
the same answer.
We didn't plan any of this out.
Just saying, right?
-No.
I have no idea what's going on.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay.
All right, here we go.
I will read
the first question about me.
All right?
Here we go.
And then, we'll see
if we have the same answer.
What condiment do I hate?
-Oh, my God.
I thought you said "continent."
[ Laughter ]
-There is one continent
I really hate.
♪♪
All right.
Here's my real answer.
You wrote down your answer.
All right.
What did you write?
-I just guessed because
everyone hates this one.
My answer is mayonnaise.
-The correct answer
is mayonnaise!
Yes!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm telling you,
I'm telling you.
-That's right.
-We're gonna do this.
I'm telling you,
we are best friends.
I do not like mayonnaise.
It reminds me of pus.
All right, here we go.
Moving on to the --
-I didn't mind it
until you just said that.
-It is your --
[ Laughter ]
It's your turn to read a
question that's about you.
And I -- I have not seen this,
and I am not looking.
-Oh.
I mean, this one is so easy.
What Oscar-nominated movie
was I in?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You -- You or me?
You were in
an Oscar-nominated --
-No, I was in
an Oscar-nominated movie,
but you have a Grammy,
and I don't.
So let's figure this out.
-I was in
an Oscar-winning movie.
-Ugh!
[ Audience groans ]
-Wait. Was "Sing 2" --
not "Sing" --
-Yeah, "Sing 2" got an Oscar.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait! I think I know this.
♪♪
No. Did --
I think so.
I --
Yeah, I think
I remember you in this.
Oh, no.
Did I make it up?
All right.
I think you were in --
if I'm correct --
"A Star is Born"?
-Yes.
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah! You were in it!
You see, I told you!
I know you!
I love you!
I told you, bud!
-I didn't think --
I didn't think you remembered.
-Don't doubt me.
Don't doubt me.
I'm telling you, we are BFFs.
-I didn't think you would
remember because I'm only in it
for like a minute.
-But I did remember
that you were in it.
'Cause I was like --
But you were also in "Sing 2."
-I was, yeah.
-Because I loved --
I love your voice.
-Thank you.
-And I go,
"You should be in more --"
-I should play
more animated wolves?
[ Laughter ]
-You're very funny in that.
All right, I'm gonna
read the next "ques-chon."
Which is, in France,
how they say "question."
[ Laughter ]
"Ques-chon."
-I'm learning
so many languages today.
[ Laughter ]
-What --
What did I want to be
before I was interested
in comedy?
-I know this one!
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. You do?
-Yes, but I just realized
I can't spell, but it's okay.
I think I spelled it.
-Really?
You knew this?
-I do know this one.
-What?!
-I do.
-This is bizarre!
-Aah!
-All right.
I'm gonna show you.
[ Drum roll ]
No.
You show me yours first.
-No.
Is that how it goes?
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-A priest.
Oh, actually you are right,
but I said mailman.
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry, I thought --
You know --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
You know what's funny, though?
Because you're actually correct.
I did want to be a priest.
-So I know you
better than you know you.
-Yeah, but I went
through a phase
where I really got into
being a mailman.
[ Laughter ]
No, I was gonna be a priest --
-I mean, they're both about
deliverance, right?
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, that's so funny.
Gosh, you're right!
You know more about me than me.
That is exactly right.
All right.
But we're still doing great.
Let's do one more.
It's your turn to read.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-Okay. Where did the name
Halsey come from?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I'm writing in all caps.
My answer looks very aggressive.
[ Laughter ]
-The name Halsey comes from...
I'm a big fan, so I definitely
better get this one, Jimmy.
I'm gonna say,
your real name is Ashley,
and you mixed up the letters.
-Okay.
Technically, you are right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But...
I got it from the street
in Brooklyn,
the stop off the L-train.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-The judges are giving it to us!
-Oh, it's insane!
It's insane!
-I think we did well.
Judges, how did we do?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
We are BFFs!
Halsey, everybody!
"About-Face" launches on
ulta.com tomorrow
and in Ulta stores this summer.
Their new song, "So Good,"
is out now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More "Tonight Show"
when we come back.
Come on back, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]